depuis septembre angélique étudie à
l'école de la deuxième chance de trappes
elle revient tout juste d'un voyage à
malte organisé par le centre de musique
baroque de versailles
elle a pu découvrir la création de la
pièce atys en folie un univers qui lui
était jusque là inconnu
c'était pourra découvrir la musique
baroque donc sur un spectacle parodique
avec orchestre baroque en fait j'avais
jamais assisté de façon une pièce de
théâtre ont plus rien même pas le
concert mois en fait c'était vraiment le
voyage plein de découvertes cinq
stagiaires se sont envolés direction le
festival de musique baroque à la valette
un voyage mené dans le cadre de
génération lully ce projet pédagogique
initié en octobre 2016 a pour mission de
sensibiliser les trappistes à l'art
baroque
on a vu le travail de toute l'équipe qui
a travaillé ce que faisait les décors on
avait les marines et testo c'est ce
qu'ils ont créé on avait des costumières
les maquilleuses des coiffeuses
on a rarement vu le spectacle en fait de
l'intérieur n'ont pas de l'extérieur
c'était génial
c'est un univers qui ne connaissent pas
forcément donc c'était leur faire
découvrir ma des choses qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de voir et de l'autre côté de
pas perdre de vue aussi la partie
professionnelle
une des exigences par rapport au travail
le travail en équipe
le savoir est des choses qui donc ils
vont avoir besoin on va dire mon leur
futur lors de leur futur métier
ce voyage aura même susciter des
vocations musicales depuis lors autour
angelica hicks état envisage de débuter
l'apprentissage d'un instrument
après la première mondiale à malte atys
en folie sera présenté à la maurice de
trappes le 2 mars